sommet européen à Copenhague les neufs
décidés à stabiliser les monnaies à
lutter contre le terrorisme et à
protéger les côtes de la pollution
marée noire que fait-on du pétrole
récupérer sur les plages un reportage
d'Henri galet
bombe à neutrons réaction hostile de
Moscou après la décision américaine dans
suspendre la fabrication pour en parler
l'invité du journal le général Georges
buy spécialiste des problèmes de
stratégie militaires
Madame Mademoiselle Monsieur bonsoir la
reine margrette du Danemark et son époux
le prince Enrique plus connu chez nous
sous le nom d'Henri de Montpezat feront
une visite officielle en France au mois
d'octobre prochain une visite qui répond
à une invitation lancée par Monsieur
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing mais il ne
s'agit là si je puis dire que du
résultat marginal du sommet qui s'est
tenu à Copenhague hier et aujourd'hui en
terre danoise donc pendant ces deux
jours les 9 chefs d'État ou bien de
gouvernement responsables des pays du
marché commun ont fait littéralement un
tour complet de l'actualité mondiale il
a été question du terrorisme de la
menace cubaine en Afrique des problèmes
économiques posés par le Japon de la
pollution mais aussi et surtout des
problèmes économiques et monétaires sur
ce sujet les 9 semblent d'ailleurs cette
nuit à peu près d'accord Maurice berther
Blade nous envoyer spéciaux à Copenhague
a d'ailleurs demandé au président de la
République comment l'Europe entendait
trouver un remède au problème de la
stabilité monétaire
voilà je crois que nous avons entendre
tout de suite le président de la
République
l'orientation qui maintenant vont être
utilisées par les institutions
compétentes dans les différents domaines
nous avons mis l'accents sur la
nécessité de rétablir un système stable
de taux de change dans la communauté et
c'est maintenant aux institutions de la
communauté de faire des propositions à
cet égard mais j'ai indiqué je vous le
rappelle que la France était disposée en
ce qui la concerne a apporté sa
contribution au rétablissement d'une
plus grande stabilité dans les taux de
change à l'intérieur de la communauté
mais je vous le disais lors de ce
sommaire européen de Copenhague donc les
chefs d'État ou de gouvernement européen
ont aussi évoqué d'autres problèmes
parmi ces problèmes la pollution marine
mais aussi et là uniquement par le
Président de la République française
lors de sa conférence de presse les
rapports sur les problèmes
internationaux entre le gouvernement
français et l'opposition dans notre pays
je vous rappelle que la politique
étrangère de la France est une politique
indépendante conduite dans le respect de
nos obligations internationales et de
nos alliances
cette politique
comporte d'abord un effort pour
aboutir à l'organisation de la
Confédération de l'Europe c'est un
objectif auquel nous sommes attachés
auquel je contribue par des initiatives
régulières et je crois que la réunion de
ces deux jours a été positive à cet
égard ensuite la politique étrangère de
la France est au service de la paix et
de la liberté
de la paix ce qui veut dire la poursuite
de la politique de détente et on a pu
observer dans la période récente que
cette politique que de détente
méritaient à l'heure actuelle de voir se
déployer de nouveaux efforts
et également la paix par exemple nous
participons à l'heure actuelle lorsqu'il
concerne le Proche-Orient à un effort
pour établir à la fois des situations
Pacifique en même temps pour assurer
l'intégrité et la souveraineté des États
de la région et ce sera toujours notre
ligne c'est-à-dire paix et liberté en
même temps la politique étrangère de la
France cherche à apporter sa
contribution à la solution de problèmes
mondiaux parce qu'à l'heure actuelle il
faut bien voir que beaucoup de problèmes
qui se posent même dans notre vie
quotidienne sur les problèmes de
dimension mondiale on a eu du mal à s'y
habituer je citerai le cas de cette
catastrophe qui a frappé la Bretagne et
bien la solution de ce problème est une
solution internationale au niveau
mondial ce ne sont pas des des solutions
de caractère local
quels sont ces grands problèmes mondiaux
il y a d'abord le problème du
désarmement ou de la limitation des
armements la France élabore une doctrine
que j'ai exposée moi-même dans un mois
et demi aux Nations Unies
tel problème du danger nucléaire ce
qu'on appelle la prolifération nucléaire
la France participe actuel dans un
certain nombre de délibérations à cette
à cet égard il y a le problème de la
situation économique et monétaire
internationale pour mettre fin à la
situation de crise dans l'ensemble du
monde et là vous participerons à cette
conférence au sommet du mois de juillet
et il y a enfin les immenses problèmes
des pays en développement et des pays du
tiers-monde vis-à-vis desquels la France
entend maintenir une attitude de
coopération et d'ouverture tout en
respectant bien entendu leur
indépendance et le libre choix de leurs
options politiques et sociales qui sont
bien entendu de leurs compétences et de
leur souveraineté voilà si vous voulez
l'attitude générale de la politique
étrangère de la France alors une
dernière question monsieur le Président
pourrait évoquer certains de ces grands
problèmes de politique étrangère
inviteraient vous de nouveau les grands
leaders de l'opposition à venir l'Elysée
comme vous l'avez fait il y a deux
semaines pour parler des problèmes
français oui et d'ailleurs je le leur ai
dit parce que je considère que c'est
utile que c'est normal que sur les
grands sujets nous allons avoir dans la
période à venir comme je vous le dis
quelques grands sujets intéressants
notre vie nationale et je compte Mon
entretenir de façon approfondie en leur
donnant tous les éléments d'information
et d'appréciation avec les grands
dirigeants de l'opposition
l'un des sujets dont on a donc parlé le
président de la République nous le
rappelait à l'instant à Copenhague c'est
celui du désarmement sans que l'on sache
toutefois s'il a été très précisément
question de la bombe à neutrons vous le
savez le président Carter hier soir a
décidé de sursauteur à la Fabrique à la
fabrication de cet engin en dépit de
l'opinion des généraux américains qui
étaient très favorable une décision qui
n'a pas surpris toutefois on s'y
attendait depuis plusieurs jours mais
qui est différemment commenté
aujourd'hui dans le monde dans quelques
instants nous allons voir quels sont les
réactions aussi bien à Washington
kamosku ou bien à bonnes alors tout
d'abord pour être clair je crois qu'il
faudrait expliquer ce qu'est cette bombe
à neutrons général Buisse vous êtes avec
nous ce soir alors s'agit-il d'un engin
essentiel pour la Défense de l'Occident
on pas du tout
je crois que les conditions les qualités
techniques de la bombe à neutrons sont
connus on en a parlé depuis plusieurs
jours qui émet énormément de radiations
les adversaires résument en disant pas
de destruction rien que des morts
mais il faut mettre cette bombe à sa
place dans la panoplie des armes
nucléaires et à ce moment-là on
s'aperçoit qu'elle est un caractère
c'est-à-dire qu'elle fait partie des
armes dit tactiques des armes du champ
de bataille de ces armes dont les
nucléaires ont stocké des quantités 7000
en ce qui concerne les Américains en
Europe pour
contrebalancer les la supériorité de
force conventionnelle de l'adversaire
ces forces-là c'est ces armes là elles
existent depuis longtemps et on les
perfectionne on les change de temps en
temps il se trouve que l'on a mis au
point cette bombe cette bombe à neutrons
depuis très longtemps d'ailleurs et que
au niveau du champ de bataille au niveau
ce que j'appellerais de la grosse
artillerie en prenant en disant que
l'obus au lieu d'être un obus au
traînésaire quel que soit le moyen avec
lequel on l'envoie entre 25 et 200 km et
bien c'est dans ce créneau là que se
situe le la bombe à neutrons ce n'est
donc pas
quelque chose de déterminant dans
l'équilibre des grands est-ce qu'on peut
faire une comparaison parce que l'on
pourrait dire que la bombe à neutrons
roule Pluton français par exemple c'est
à peu près sensiblement la même chose
bien sûr sauf que là elle met plus de
neutrons que l'autre et que un jour les
Français peuvent parfaitement modifier
le projectile de leur python mais c'est
exactement la même chose c'est pas du
tout le même c'est pas du tout la même
menace ni même emploi nous reverrons
tout à l'heure en général vous restez
avec nous nous allons voir tout d'abord
les réactions causées par cette donc
cette décision du président Carter des
réactions qui ne vont pas tous toutes
pardon dans le même sens ainsi aux
Etats-Unis même la décision du chef de
l'exécutif américain est loin de faire
l'unanimité on savait que le Pentagone
c'est-à-dire les militaires et
défavorables à la construction de la
bombe à neutron mais une bonne partie
des membres du Congrès ont rejoint les
militaires et on craint là-bas que la
bombe à neutrons soit finalement
abandonnée comme là déjà été il y a
quelques mois le bombardier B1 et comme
dit-on le sera peut-être abandonné aussi
un jour le missile de croisière
Washington Jacques Séguy
er sur sa propre morale à toute arme
nucléaire sont désirs de faire pression
sur l'Union soviétique avant une
éventuelle rencontre Carter Brig
itte soviétique et américain devrait
signer cette année le deuxième traité
soldes sur la limitation des armements
stratégiques Carter en renonçant la
bombe à neutrons espèrent obtenir
l'allègement des troupes conventionnels
soviétiques et des fusées tourner vers
le rap occidentale les Américains
redoutent ce matin que l'image de leur
président soit perçue une fois encore
comme celle de l'indécision et de
l'utopie
de l'autre côté c'est à dire dans les
pays de l'Est cette fois-ci la décision
du président Carter n'a pas été disons
mieux accueilli là-bas à Moscou on y
voit un chantage pour les autorités
soviétiques le président Carter ne
cherche finalement que obtenir des
concessions de la part de l'URSS sur le
problème global du désarmement Moscou
Jacques dauphin l'agence principale mar
chande numéro 1 soviétique hier à
vladivost et il a ajouté l'ours plantant
point cédé un tel marchand d'art
aujourd'hui
l'agence face affirme que le président
capteur fait dépendre sa décision la
journée la production de la bombe de
concession de la part de l'URSS pour
Moscou il existe deux problèmes qui ne
sont pas liés alors qu'ils sont liés par
les Américains d'une part les accords de
limitation des armements stratégiques et
d'autre part l'arme à neutrons armée
tactique en tant que pète dans telle
condition le voyage de Monsieur sai
rosswans le prêter des Américains Moscou
les vins et 21 avril prochain
difficulté et encore plus la prochaine
session spéciale de l'ONU sur le
désarmement en mai prochain
reste enfin l'opinion de ce chez qui
cette bombe devait être installée
c'est-à-dire l'opinion des Allemands de
l'autre côté du Rhin ces opinions sont
divergentes ainsi si la majorité
actuellement au pouvoir a bien accueilli
la décision du président Carter
l'opposition est notamment monsieur
Franz Yosef Strauss ont été très
critiques pour Monsieur Strauss c'est la
première fois qu'un président américain
s'incline devant un tsar russe
pro-américain incontesté Frances a
considéré ses décisions américaines
comme un agentouillement sans précédent
de l'Amérique devant la Russie des tsars
et cela dans l'après-guerre c'est là une
réaction assez violente bien entendu
mais la décision du président américain
est d'une façon générale considérée en
Allemagne comme la preuve supplémentaire
de son incapacité de gouverner et d'agir
les plus modérés parlent bien entendu
d'un président Carter un calculable de
fait ces décisions américaines enlèvent
un atout non négligeable à des Allemands
obsédés de sécurité face aux chars
soviétiques parqués dans l'Allemagne de
l'Est notamment cette renonciation est
donc considérée comme un cadeau sans
contrepartie et soviétique et cela sur
le dos de la sécurité des Allemands on
voudrait nous jeter dans les bras des
Soviétiques qu'on ne ferait pas mieux
disent déçus et choqués des Allemands et
ça jusque dans l'entourage du chancelier
Schmidt ici au cours du sommet de
Copenhague à quelques semaines de la
visite à bonnes en mai prochain de
Léonie de Brejnev c'est bien entendu là
une situation assez exceptionnelle elle
va plus ou moins vulnérabiliser si l'on
peut dire le chancelier Schmidt par
rapport à son interlocuteur soviétique
dire à en partant de là que l'Allemagne
de l'Ouest est éventuellement à vendre à
l'Est reste néanmoins tout à fait
absurde dernière réaction celle de la
France et bien ce soir on a l'impression
que ce problème de la bande de la bombe
à neutrons de la concerne pas la
décision du président Carter ne
modifiera pas la position française en
matière d'armement nucléaire la France
dit-on dans les milieux autorisés
continuera à se déterminer en fonction
de ses intérêts propres alors général
vous êtes toujours à vous avec nous
peut-on dire que la France se
désintéresse totalement de ce style
d'armement nucléaire grâce à Dieu elle
s'est donné les moyens de son
désintéresser cette inquiétude que nous
voyons s'exprimer exprime
et comment dire il est normal les pays
européens sont nus sur le plan nucléaire
il dépend d'un grand moteur en matière
nucléaire la France est donnée un outil
nucléaire et surtout une stratégie et la
stratégie de dissuasion du faible au
fort qui est la stratégie de suffisance
qui ne cherche pas à se donner les
moyens massifs de coercition sur
l'adversaire mais qui permet de le comme
on dit de le décourager d'entreprendre
donc notre système d'armes nucléaire si
vous voulez nous parler des Pluton tout
à l'heure qui pourrait être l'équivalent
de ces têtes nucléaires perfectionnées
que serait les que serait les bombes à
neutrons et bien ne sont pas là pour
gagner la bataille dans un échange
d'atoi à moi mais sont là pour tenir un
discours pour dire attention nous ne
jouons pas votre guerre et tout de suite
après nous passons au feu stratégique
c'est-à-dire celui sur vos cités donc ne
commencez pas ce jeu et nous en sommes
donnés les moyens de cette stratégie les
systèmes d'armes et les systèmes
d'autorisation et ce qu'on appelle aussi
la gesticulation possible de cette
stratégie maintenant est-ce qu'on peut
dire que cette histoire de Monotron
finalement ça fait partie de ce grand
jeu de poker qui sépare les Américains
des Soviétiques sur les problèmes du
désarmement marchandage est vrai il y a
9 ans que les Américains et les
Soviétiques discutent sur la limitation
des armements
stratégiques c'est le débat du siècle
c'est le débat de la bipolarité c'est le
débat de l'équilibre du monde qui se
passe entre eux pensaient bien que la
bombe à neutrons joue un rôle tout à
fait négligeable
sont toujours les Américains qui font
ils ont abandonné le bombardier B1 alors
qu'il y a le bombardé bexfeurs
on peut se poser la question ils peuvent
abandonner le christmicil et ensuite
sortir
le carter est en train d'obtenir en
contrepartie quant au rythme de
construction de l'avion backside savoir
si on fera non plus le missile le
missile des sous-marins SSN x18 qui est
une énorme bête soviétique qui porte à
12000 km 25 Mo toutes choses là sont en
discussion et ce sont ces grandes armes
du sommet les Américains disposent de
12000 armes mégatoniques
intercontinentales dans 9500 sous la mer
vous pensez bien que le problème de la
sécurité des Européens il est beaucoup
plus dans la non des stabilité des
rapports des deux grands
à travers des phases successives des
accords sols et il faut absolument qu'il
y ait une phase qui aboutissent les
Soviétiques qui tiennent autant que les
Américains et on ne va pas se laisser
arrêter du moins quand on est un des
deux grands par les histoires de
Mogadiscio par les histoires de de
feu
de bombe à neutrons par les missiles de
croisière tout ça dans un futur accord
sera fait de plusieurs parties avec un
traité avec un protocole qui va geler
certains de ces matériels à certains
temps et puis avec des propositions pour
que à l'avenir on aille plus loin il ne
faut pas arrêter ce mécanisme personne
n'est perdant dans cette histoire
Carter a remis dans sa poche un 635
d'alarme et à conservé à 155 bien sûr la
sortie la déclaration qu'on allait faire
la bombe à neutrons c'était ça qui était
le marchandage ce n'est pas le fait
qu'on l'abandonne merci mon général
c'est aussi d'armes américaines dont il
est question aujourd'hui si l'on en
croit l'un des représentants américains
au Congrès des armes américaines et
notamment des bombes à billes aurait été
utilisés par les Israéliens lors de
l'enfant siffle mené par les troupes
israéliennes dans le sud du Liban c'est
bon baby appelé aussi bon bah
fragmentation avec causer de lourdes
pertes au sein de la population
libanaise en Israël même la politique
menée par Monsieur Ménard reine begin
semble cependant obtenir le soutien
quasi total de la population on disait
le Premier ministre israélien
sérieusement contesté à la fois au
Parlement et dans la rue cette
contestation semble pourtant de toucher
qu'une minorité et la cote de popularité
de Monsieur ménakhem begin reste
actuellement largement au-dessus des 50%
le taux de popularité de Monsieur begin
a baissé il se situe autour de 60%, une
manifestation organisée à Tel-Aviv par
un groupe de 300 officiers de réserve
réunis près de 30 000 personnes avec des
slogans tels que la Paix Maintenant
plutôt que le Grand Israël alors peut-on
en conclure que le pouvoir de Monsieur
begin est menacé par la rue et qu'il a
de sérieuses difficultés de politique
intérieure le penser serait je crois le
résultat d'une analyse un peu rapide en
effet la majorité des Israéliens
continuent à croire que monsieur bedine
est le seul homme capable de gouverner
aujourd'hui en Israël et même les
dirigeants de ce mouvement pour la paix
maintenant qui ont installé à piqué de
sympathisants avec des pancartes juste
en face de la résidence du Premier
ministre estime que leur action n'est
pas dirigée contre Monsieur begging pour
qui ils ont une grande sympathie
nous n'avons
aucun doute
dans la loyauté de Monsieur béguin
envers son pays et la sincérité de son
désir de paix mais nous avons
l'impression que Monsieur begging est
dirigé
par une conception
de laquelle il est partisan il y a déjà
plusieurs dizaines d'années conceptions
qui
envisage
la réalisation des droits historiques du
peuple juif en Judée et en Samory comme
un élément vital du futur et de
l'existence de d'Israël
nous soutenons qu'une politique dirigée
en parlent par tel principe est une
politique qui fait qui pose des
obstacles dans la voie de la paix dans
les nouvelles circonstances qui ont été
créées par l'initiative du président
s'adapte est-ce que vous croyez vous à
la sincérité votre mouvement la
sincérité du président Sadate pour la
paix
nous n'avons aucune base de douter cette
sincérité
Israël doit faire aujourd'hui des
concessions
nous croyons qu'il serait doit se porter
prête à faire des concessions en échange
d'une paix complète
même ceux qui en Israël sont prêts à
toutes les concessions quand même une
méfiance à l'égard du président Sadate
et des Arabes c'est là un des atouts de
Monsieur begging qui connaît cette sorte
de fuite en avant de peur de l'avenir un
homme fort rassure les Israéliens même
s'il le critiquent vieux routier de la
politique avec un passé prestigieux et
des actions d'éclats pendant le mandat
britannique monsieur begin a un côté
théâtral bon orateur il s'est en toute
occasion rappeler sa position sur les
négociations et la paix avec l'Egypte
comme ici au cours d'une réception où on
lui remet un diplôme de docteur en
philosophie il dramatise sévère fermé il
affirme tout faire pour que la paix
s'établisse mais en même temps il
rappelle que ceux qui prime avant tout
pour lui c'est la sécurité et sur cela
il est un trait able
après avoir tenu tête au président
Carter ne craignant rien du côté de
l'opposition seul à pouvoir maintenir la
coalition gouvernementale monsieur begin
doit maintenant et rapidement faire un
choix un choix difficile certes mais un
choix qui engage l'avenir de tout le
Proche-Orient en aura-t-il la force
politique et le courage personnel
en politique française après des
weekends bien chargés des week-ends
électoraux nous aurions pu vivre une fin
de semaine particulièrement calme si le
RP r n'avait décidé de tenir un congrès
demain dimanche il est vrai que la
principale formation de la majorité
connaît quelques problèmes en ce moment
des problèmes qui Daniel Brême amène
même son président Monsieur Jacques
Chirac a vouloir modifier les statues du
rassemblement alors s'agit-il de la
troisième étape de la bataille du
perchoir risque d'apparaître ainsi
puisque non seulement il s'agit
d'exclure des organismes de direction du
parti les ministres mais aussi
maintenant le président de l'Assemblée
nationale or cette mesure n'avait pas
été prévue initialement elle ne l'a été
que 48 heures après justement l'élection
de Monsieur Chaban-Delmas en résumé il
s'agit donc de mettre en congé de parti
tous ceux qui collaborent de près ou de
loin avec le pouvoir
des militants ça serait tenté de vous
dire oui non oui parce que il y a 1200
congressistes et que là les
parlementaires sont en minorité et non
parce que les députés estiment que
Monsieur Chaban-Delmas est un élu au
même titre que et il trouve cette mesure
injuste monsieur Guichard lui la trouve
regrettable mais à travers cette
querelle il y a une autre bataille qui
se profile derrière c'est que les
députés craignent de perdre une partie
de leur autonomie d'action sous la
pression de leur partie et évidemment là
les choses ne veulent se passeront pas
forcément aussi facilement c'est à dire
que les élus craignent finalement de
voir le parti empiété sur leur
prérogative exactement ils prennent de
perdre un peu de liberté et Monsieur
Chirac évidemment sur ce thème ne sera
pas mis en difficulté car il a choisi de
resserrer les rangs sur les grands
principes c'est à dire au nom des thèmes
gaullistes qui ont été défendus pendant
les élections il va demander aux députés
et au sénateurs de croiser le fer sur
l'Europe l'économie la monnaie la
proportionnelle exactement donc là
évidemment il ne peut pas y avoir
discussion cela il est évident que en se
faisant monsieur Chirac entend faire que
son parti ne soit pas noyé au sein de la
majorité il veut montrer que il a 153
députés et que cela pèse et il espère
également que la petite musique
giscardienne n'arrivera pas diffuser son
groupe
nous vous retrouvons demain à 13h et
aussi à 20h la marée noire plus de 6500
personnes travaillent actuellement pour
nettoyer les plages et les criques du
nord de la Bretagne souillée par la
pollution causée par lamoko caddie sur
ces 6500 personnes à peu près on compte
3500 militaires certaines informations
laissaient entendre hier que des
militaires et même des bénévoles avaient
été atteints de troubles imputables aux
produits pétroliers des versets par la
mokocalise le ministère de la Santé a
démenti aujourd'hui ces informations
sur place en tout cas on continue et
vous le savez à ramasser ce pétrole les
opérations vont bons trains et certains
maintenant se posent une question que
va-t-on faire de cette marée noire ainsi
récupérer et bien on rigolait en
Bretagne a enquêté pour le savoir
pour évacuer le mazout liquide pas trop
de problèmes les tonalités des paysans
se sont révélés comme étant à la pointe
du progrès en matière de luth anti-marée
noire elle pompe le pétrole sur les
plages puis les 400 camions-citernes
prennent le relais et par la voie ferrée
ou par mère ce mazout est envoyé en fin
vers les stations de dégazage de Brest
ou du Havre
en temps normal ces stations de dégazage
reçoivent les eaux de lavage chargés de
résidus d'huile des pétroliers la
station de Brest accueille des navires
jusqu'à 250 000 tonnes depuis le début
de la marée noire on a traité ici 9000
mètres cubes de mélange eau de mer
pétrole sur ces 9000 mètres cubes le
tiers est transformé en huile puis en
full lourd ce fioul sert ensuite de
combustible pour les besoins de la
station de dégazage
le gros problème c'est surtout celui des
déchets solides que est mon mazouté
mélange sable pétrole on se souvient du
Bollène les 5000 tonnes de détritus
avaient été dans un premier temps stocké
sur l'île de Sein puis enterré près de
Quimper déterré et stocké à nouveau pour
faire face à ces difficultés des cubes
de stockage sont en cours de
construction puis dans un deuxième temps
les déchets solides seront incinérés par
une usine qui sera achevée à Brest dans
6 mois
enterrer non il n'est pas question de
recommencer une opération qui avait eu
lieu je crois à Quimper c'est pour ça
qu'ici on met dans ses bacs spécialement
aménagés et que les gens du terrain je
peux vous dire qu'est-ce que vous
attendez pour aller plus vite bah
justement on va en travail jour et nuit
c'était éclairé mais on fait quelque
chose qui n'a aucun risque et vous
pouvez d'ailleurs aller voir sur place
qui pourrait d'ailleurs recevoir 70
mètres de hauteur d'eau avec des
cailloux en dessous pointus
pour avoir une idée de l'importance de
ces déchets il faut multiplier les 230
000 tonnes de pétrole de la mokokanis
par 5 ce qui donnera au moins un million
de tonnes de rebus à détruire le
traitement des déchets devra donc être
étalé sur plusieurs mois
puisque l'opération marée noire en
Bretagne est entrée dans sa phase
d'évacuation les autorités devraient en
profiter pour pomper les 4000 litres de
fioul que contient ce cargo couler au
milieu de la mer Benoît c'est ce que
demande les pêcheurs de l'endroit les
paves est ici depuis un an personne ne
s'en est encore occupé le bateau
s'appelle le Belon
voilà pour l'essentiel de l'actualité de
cette journée mais puisque nous sommes
samedi dernier jour de la semaine je
vous propose de refaire connaissance
avec un acteur tout à fait exceptionnel
il s'appelle Roger kodgio et comme
certains acteurs orientaux qui
interprètent le même rôle durant toute
leur vie en le perfectionnant certes
sans cesse Roger Coggio reprend une
nouvelle fois au Théâtre de la
Renaissance le journal d'un fou d'après
Nicolas Gogol une pièce qu'il avait créé
il y a 16 ans déjà une pièce qui fera
d'ailleurs partie des programmes de fin
d'année sur Antenne 2 nous allons
retrouver
kodgio dans le journal d'un fou de
Nicolas cogol
il s'est produit un incident qu'aucune
plume ne peut pas
la porte est ouverte je me suis levé
aussitôt mes papiers à la main croyant
que c'était notre directeur
or cet été
elle m'a adressé un petit salut et m'a
dit
il y a 16 ans que vous jouez cette pièce
pourquoi pourquoi parce que c'est un
dictionnaire d'une part d'autre part et
là c'est tant mieux j'ai l'âge
maintenant du personnage que je n'avais
pas il y a 16 ans et puis rares sont les
rôles qui recoupent comme ça toute la
gamme de la panoplie des sentiments
humains je veux dire c'est inouï à part
des choses qu'on trouve dans hamley dans
Shakespeare comme Hamlet etc alors la
scène que nous venons de voir c'est dans
le début de la pièce absolument oui
c'est le moment d'une des rencontres
avec Sophie la fille de son directeur
dont il était perdu moi amoureux mais il
est peut-être plus amoureux de sa
condition sociale de son statut dans la
société que d'elle-même il la sacralise
il idéalise mais elle est pas forcément
très belle et c'est pour ça qu'il veut
devenir le roi d'Espagne c'est pour ça
qu'il veut devenir un personnage
considérable pour être hiérarchiquement
supérieur à son père parce qu'à ce
moment-là il pense avoir le regard des
autres l'amour des autres c'est une
pièce qui repousse finalement sur
l'amour
aujourd'hui est un jour de grandes
solennité
c'est le côté pathologique du personnage
qui vous a attiré vous êtes allé dans
des asiles à nos pas du tout j'ai pas
voulu me documenter le côté pathologique
j'ai pas voulu en tenir compte
en tout cas moi je peux vous dire une
chose c'est que
ce personnage je joue comme si j'étais
pas fou
le journal d'un fou Roger cojio
actuellement au Théâtre de la
Renaissance et à la fin de l'année donc
sur Antenne 2 la météo pour demain dans
l'extrême sud de OST en Corse les nuages
resteront assez abondant avec de la
pluie ou bien des averses de la Bretagne
à la Flandre et au nord des Vosges les
nuages matinaux feront place
l'après-midi à des éclaircies passagères
sur le reste de la France le temps frais
et localement brumeux le matin se rend
ensuite bien insolit voilà c'est
l'édition de samedi est terminée aux
alentours de 23h30 vous retrouverez avec
l'autre qui est à mes côtés pour vous
présenter notre dernier journal de cette
journée quant à moi j'espère vous
retrouver demain à 13h bonne soirée